chileans have elected the leftist former
student protest leader gabriel borrich
as their new president following one of
the most polarizing elections in decades
there supporters of the progressive
social democrats celebrated the victory
in santiago de chile boric ran on a
platform in support of public education
health care and equal rights for
indigenous and lgbtq people his opponent
farm right ultra conservative jose
antonio cast phone borrich and conceded
defeat cast was seen as the law and
order candidate
let's go straight to dw correspondent
benjamin alvarez gruber who's covering
the election for us benjamin you're in
downtown santiago how is the victory of
gabrielle borrich being received in the
chilean capital
[Music]
good afternoon anthony there are still
people around here in the capital
santiago there is still music on stage
the president-elect gabriel boris
already addressed the crowd there are
people celebrating they are singing and
of course they are happy that after jose
antonio caste farad candidate that you
just mentioned won the first round now
it's the turn of the former student
protest leader there were a lot of
people coming to the center of uh of
this of the stage that's right nearby in
the center of santiago and we were able
to talk to some of his supporters who
came here to celebrate that he will be
the next president of chile let's listen
i'm very happy and full of hope now
change can happen change that we have
wanted for more than two years or for 30
years
i'm very emotional this is a historic
moment like nothing that has ever
happened there's no precinct in the
history of chile it's truly emotional
we've made so much progress now we will
move forward with social rights continue
to advance and fight against the far
right
i feel tremendous joy i was here when i
was 15 years old celebrating the defeat
of pinochet now again we see that hope
is back hope for a more united and just
country even with all the things that
remain to be done
some chilean voters there reacting to
the victory of gabrielle borac talk to
us a little bit more about the man
gabriel burrich benjamin what does he
stand for
he stands for to continue the work of
this constitutional assembly that was
drafted after the massive protest the
rock chile in 2019 with a severe human
rights crisis in this country he talked
to the victims of this human rights
violation saying that they will be
investigated that the perpetrators will
be punished he is also in favor of
including the indigenous population it
will be one of the central points of
this constitutional assembly that is
already drafting a new constitution that
will replace the constitution that dates
back to 1980 at the time of the
dictatorship of augusto pinochet we just
heard one man talking about the pinochet
dictatorship as well in memories that he
has today and it shows that the
dictatorship is also an important day
today not only because gabrielle bourage
also wants to see this human rights
abuse as punished but also because his
opponent jose antonio cast the far-right
candidate was is still an admirer of
the dictatorship of agusto pinochet what
was made during the dictatorship so this
is indeed something very interesting
it's a polarizing election it was a
polarizing day as well something that
many call the most important
presidential election since the return
to democracy in 1990
from santiago chile dw correspondent
benjamin alvarez-gruber many thanks
well let's bring in latin america expert
gunther myhold here he works at the
german institute for international and
security affairs here in berlin good to
have you with us now gabrielle borich is
not only the youngest candidate who ever
got elected in chile he also got more
votes than any other presidential
candidate in the history of the country
how do you explain his success
he's a representative of a new
generation he has about half of the age
of the actual president sebastian pinera
and he is a representative
of the student and social movement of
the
2019
demonstrations on the streets
and at the same time he represents a new
generation of political actors because
all the old parties of the transition
period of the chilean democracy have
been losing place and he is now
on the front of a social movement
government which will generate new
topics new electoral
uh perspectives for the people
so a new generation of leadership but
the challenges that have been plaguing
chile are still very much the same what
are those challenges that the new
president will have to prioritize
he has been
given a clear program to the people he
wants a reform of the
development model and goodbye to
neoliberal model where chile has been
the forerunner in the years
of the past decades and he wants to
generate a new type of politics this
means that he has to
come to a model to include the citizens
on the street to generate new forums to
make policy and at the same time to have
the space with the constitutional
assembly to
write a new constitution
okay there are pressing uh social and
economic challenges in the country as
well he's a new genera he represents a
new generation you say well other
countries in latin america are also
struggling they've been looking for
changes too
oh they've been watching this election
how important is this election for other
countries in the region what what signal
does it give to
them at the first side it seems that the
progressive part of the political
systems in latin america will be
strengthened by this but we must be
clear that there is a heterogeneous
cooperation between these different
countries lula is the old generation
porridge is the new generation though i
think we will have a push to a left
oriented governments but at the same
time we have to be clear that they will
be interested in quite different uh
questions in the internal side and
porridge will have some sort of new
leadership that the old man can't
represent
gunter myholt from the german institute
for international security affairs thank
you very much
you're welcome